hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde wie ihr seht es bereits
im titel eingeblendet sind sehr
trauriges thema heute und zwar mache ich
eine weltreise
ich hatte euch verlassen im spiel
ich habe humor studieren ein spaß meine
lieben freunde ich mache natürlich
selbstverständlich keine weltreise
allerdings habe ich mir klar wieder dazu
überreden lassen ein kinderspiel zu
spielen ja schreien der begeisterung
dass die rist fiete und das ist das
zimmer und wir können halt viel zu
nehmen und irgendwo platzieren wie
beispielsweise herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen video
wir können das wasser an und ausmachen
sind ja unzählige möglichkeiten die uns
gegeben werden irgendwie können wir
alles was sie irgendwie rumsteht bewegen
ich weiß nicht einmal das leben in die
hand nehmen spätestens jetzt ist das
video nicht mehr werden freundlich dann
etwas machen mit dem ja herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video er schläft
jetzt wow jetzt schläft biete hier das
können wir auch noch nehmen wir können
die pflanzen nehmen wir können wir
können alles irgendwie gefühlt verändern
wir haben die kraft das ändert gar
nichts
hier fordern wir auch noch den
wasserhahn denkt aber auch an machen da
ist die gießkanne voll wahrscheinlich
können wir jetzt auch unternehmen wasser
wieder aus und ihm die pis damit machst
jetzt wird sich immer dass das
lagerfeuer an ich glaub ich hab das
spiel verstanden keine ahnung was sie
hier für die person ist aber ihr könnt
mich können sie das spiel ist ab 0
und ich glaube das sagt alles wir haben
hier vorne noch ein schweinchen kann das
schweinchen da auch sk jetzt sieht so
aus als würde auf einem schwein
jetzt tut mir leid dass ich immer so ein
schwachsinn hoch war die commerzbank mit
der gießkanne erster hand wir nehmen da
ist einmal die kettensäge ja jetzt gehen
wir damit zum schwein
jetzt macht er die bank kaputt oder war
es ein paar sekunden später aber pro
bank
ich kann mir einfach warum wir den baum
ab und jetzt habe ich hier holz und
jetzt sieht aus wie viele mit zwei
zimtschnecken und jetzt habe ich hunger
auf zimtschnecken ich würde sagen wir
laufen allerdings noch ein bisschen
weiter durch das hier ist die chantal
die hatten werkzeug laden irgendwie
verstehe ich nicht so ganz den sind von
diesem spiel die vornamen an strand und
hier ist ein boot bietet das hat super
geklappt mit aufs boot aufsteigen können
wir unten noch uns das anschauen hier
sind fallen wenn wir weiter gehen haben
wir noch ein paar mehr frische werden
kann ich den fisch nehmen sowie schild
jetzt auf der bank mit dem
säbelzahntiger fisch wenn wir noch ein
bisschen weiter durch den ozean
durchscrollen sehen wir noch mehr
frische werden eine schatztruhe mit zimt
schnecke und schatztruhe erreicht
nächste ich fühle mich geehrt dass auf
jeden fall das perfekte equipment um
jetzt auf dem boot zu steigen und im
auto zu steigen
und ich brauche man nicht nach den jetzt
trinkt sie wir fahren jetzt einfach mal
rückwärts mit unserem boot in richtung
brasilien hause musste spricht wir sind
ganz ganz viele fische wie sehr wir sind
da hallo alle miteinander ja wie oder
ist ein motorboot meine lieben freundin
den krebs selber mitbekommen
und jetzt haben ins wasser
ich glaube wir können irgendwo hinfahren
will second slater hallo
ja wir fahren jetzt hier lang
[Musik]
warum ist das plötzlich
das spiele ich hier wieder von euch
haben halt unter meiner letzten videos
in die kommentare geschrieben hey luca
spiel mal wieder an ich bin da mama
motor aus ja bitte setzt mehr auf dem
traktor nicht ich kann auch mit ich kann
jetzt auch mit dem traktor jetzt bremsen
brett sehr gut ja viele haben auf jeden
fall in die kommentare geschrieben
lukas wieder mal wieder den dingen
spielen kinderspiel war letztes mal echt
überhaupt nicht witzig deswegen wir das
auf gar keinen fall nochmal sehen das
heute ja ja und jetzt spielen wir hier
feed the world um genau zu sein
da steht unser brot acht moment kritisch
gut braucht man nicht vielleicht auch
mal ab
titel des echten boss jetzt werde jetzt
bei den helm auf und jetzt ab in den
helikopter mit dir und jetzt können wir
mit dem ball mit dem helikopter
irgendwie genauso fliegt man den
helikopter am das hier ist eine material
noch eine flaschenpost endlich stellen
warum darauf kann man nur das boot
obendrauf
[Musik]
ja logisch so reißig auch immer ein
urlaub wäre wenn wir jetzt noch den
traktor hier drauf acht perfekt
teilnehmer noch ein schaf mit herz ist
schwer jetzt fährt das schaf das bis
jetzt
und wir sind jetzt das wir sind jetzt
das schaf oder bieten perfekt genau in
diesem radius wollte ich mich auch
bewegen gegen die können wir jede person
hier steuern und wir können uns noch
sagen wird unter charme und jetzt gehen
wir mit dem schaf hier weiterkommen
schafft kommt das auch noch mal oben
drauf jetzt viele jetzt sieht man den
helikopter warum geht das nicht
trotzdem kommen da rein
ich bin genauso verwirrt wie ihre
freunde ich dachte das wäre so ein
entspanntes game wo wir halt irgendwie
kann es ruhig sein danke ich dachte dass
irgend so ein entspanntes game welt
sagen können und jo wir reisen ein
bisschen rum wir nehmen unseren dings
als ich meine es ist ja auch kommen wir
können alles verändern und sagen hier
das gefällt uns nicht wir schmeißen
alles in ozeane sowie die menschen das
auch machen wie der umweltverschmutzung
nehme meine lieben freunde also viele
kommt er wieder raus wir wollen jetzt
aber den ozean auf wir wollen nicht dass
er komplett verschmutzt wird soll das
kommt alles hier an den strand wieder
zurück da könnt ihr schönen grillen der
matrose so rundlich wer ist er ich bin
der boss auf den habe ich absolut gar
keinen bock den schmeißen wir hierzu dem
fisch kann nicht verstehen wie essen
miete wird sie mal rein
wir müssen natürlich vorne sitzen meine
lieben freunde jetzt können wir mit dem
helikopter hier oben fliegen was
passiert wenn wir abstürzen
ja klar wir schwimmen einfach im wasser
war allerdings wieder und fliegen mal
wieder über unsere komplette welt ich
glaube das ist einfach nur einen
rundflug den wir dann machen können also
es ist nicht so es geht in die eine
richtung und dann hört es nicht mehr auf
der openworld mäßig sondern wir fliegen
die ganze zeit im kreis weil spätestens
jetzt sind wir wieder da wo wir gerade
gestartet und dass unser typ auf dem
lande jetzt schöne geste druck
sind wir mal nicht so wäre nämlich auch
noch mit bernd leno hier auch noch vorne
drauf auf dem ding hier landen auf dem
leuchtturm das wäre interessant war dann
drehte nämlich jetzt mal um perfekt
genau da wollte ich landen
und womit verdient ihr geld ja ich weiß
jetzt nicht genau was wir noch machen
sollen also wir können auch mal ein
bisschen jeden ozeane erkunden liegt
geld hatte momente sorgt der steig mal
aus um geld hier hinken wir das gewicht
das geld irgendwie kommt ich packe das
geld einfach nach oben mit drauf dann
auch noch mit dorfverein hier und los
geht's
besser als gta und es tut einfach weh
ich weiß nicht ob wir uns von dem geld
jetzt irgendwas kaufen können
ich würde sagen dafür gehen wir einfach
mal ne da ist nichts wahr nicht
irgendwas an essens laden oder so wenn
man sich etwas zu essen ding ist das so
lieber das geld hier die du hier ja
krieg etwas vergessen weiß mal unseren
helikopter mal weg den brauchen wir
nicht die hier kann ja mal in die küche
gehen zusammen mit ihrem kumpel jetzt
was zu essen kochen macht mal was davon
haben ein plumpsklo
da können wir die tür aufmachen dann
setzen wir da drauf und zack jetzt
scheiße da ordentlich die kloschüssel
voll ja ich weiss allerdings jetzt nicht
ganz genau was wir noch machen sollen
mit im boot sind wir gefahren werden
medicopter geflogen hier vorne ist
nichts mehr schwimmen könnten wir noch
immer gibt sie keine herausforderung in
dem spiel ja interessant auf jeden fall
ich glaube dass null bis dreijährige
kinder daran auf jeden fall spaß haben
werden sich damit jahrelang beschäftigen
können ich allerdings ja auch
anscheinend wie ihr seht wir wollten
einfach ja damit ein bisschen rum
meine lieben freunde das war feed the
world mit luca und satz auf jeden fall
spaß mal ne twitter
perfekt sehe ich genauso ich würde sagen
wir bringen viele jetzt allerdings war
wieder zurück in seine bude
das war nämlich hier die haben ja so
extrem schön eingerichtet da packen wir
hier nochmal das dings drauf hier das da
vorne hier einen wikingerhelm natürlich
den zieht man ja immer an bei dem
schlafengehen um den anker packe ich mir
auch immer aufs bett aufs bett ja danke
ich mir auch immer eine wand an die wand
den anker ging ich mir an die hänge ich
an die weiße mütze schlaf einfach und
wach am besten nicht mehr auf an der
stelle habe ich das heute wieder
zahlungsausfällen meine lieben freunde
wie bereits gesagt haben wir einige von
euch geschrieben herr luca spiel mal
wieder so ein kinderspiel
sowas in der richtung sesamstraße bibi
und tina was sogar früher manchmal
gemacht hat deswegen hab ich mir dachte
der will eine weltreise machen dann
machen wir die zusammen mit viele wenns
euch gefallen hat dann das gerne einen
daumen hoch und tamedia schreibt den
morden in die kommentare
welches kinderspiele ich als nächstes
spielen soll dort würde mich auf jeden
fall interessieren und jetzt befinden es
auch schon im auto meine lieben freunde
hier oben ist die smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr keine kinder ich spiele mit
luca verpassen wollt dann klickt da gern
drauf seid dann könnt ihr einen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren verpasst halt so
ein qualitativ hochwertigen content
nicht mehr und hier ist ein anderes
kinderspiel video von mir verlangt was
ich für auch geladen habt sesamstraße
liegt das an